Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to have a look at the
state of egocentric videoconferencing. Now
this doesn’t mean that only we get to speak during
a meeting, it means that we are wearing a camera,
which looks like this, and the goal is to use
a learning algorithm to synthesize this frontal
view of us. Now note that what you see here is
the recorded reference footage, this is reality,
and this would need to be somehow synthesized
by the algorithm. If we could pull that off,
we could add a low-cost egocentric camera to smart
glasses, and it could pretend to see us from the
front, which would be amazing for hands-free
videoconferencing. That would be insanity.
But wait a second. How is this even possible?
For us to even have a fighting chance, there
are four major problems to overcome here.
One, this camera lens is very close to
us, which means that it doesn’t see the
entirety of the face. That sounds extremely
challenging. And if that wasn’t bad enough,
two, we also have tons of distortion
in the images, or in other words,
things don’t look like they look in reality,
we would have to account for that too. Three,
it would also have to take into account
our current expression, gaze, blinking,
and more. Oh boy. And finally, four, the output
needs not be photorealistic, even better,
videorealistic. Remember, we don’t just need one
image, but a continuously moving video output.
So the problem is, once
again, input, egocentric view,
output, synthesized frontal view. This is
the reference footage, reality if you will,
and now, let’s see how this learning-based
algorithm is able to reconstruct it.
Um…hello? Is this a mistake? They look
identical, as if they were just copied here.
No, you will see in a moment that it’s not a
mistake, this means that the AI is giving us a
nearly perfect reconstruction of the remainder
of the human face. That is absolutely amazing.
Now, it is still not perfect, there are some
differences. So how do we get a good feel
of where the inaccuracies are? The answer is a
difference image, look. Regions with warmer colors
indicate where the reconstruction is inaccurate
compared to the real reference footage.
For instance, with an earlier method by the name
pix2pix, the hair and the beard are doing fine,
while we have quite a bit of reconstruction
error on the remainder of the face.
So, did the new method do better than
this? Let’s have a look together. Oh yeah!
It does much better across the entirety of
the face. It still has some trouble with the
cable and the glasses, but otherwise,
this is a clean, clean image. Bravo!
Now, we talked about the challenge of
reconstructing expressions correctly.
To be able to read the other person is of
utmost importance during a video conference.
So how good is it at gestures?
Well, let’s put it through an intense
stress test! Well, this is as intense as
it gets without having access to Jim
Carrey as a test subject I suppose,
and I bet there was a lot of fun to be had in the
lab on this day. And the results are outstanding,
especially if we compare it again
to the pix2pix technique from 2017.
I love this idea, because if we can overcome
the huge shortcomings of the egocentric camera,
in return, we get an excellent view of subtle
facial expressions and can deal with the tiniest
eye movements, twitches, tongue movements,
and more. And it really shows in the results.
Now please note that this technique needs to be
trained on each of these test subjects. About
four minutes of video footage is fine and this
calibration process only needs to be done once.
So, once again, the technique knows
these people and had seen them before.
But in return, it can do even more. If all of this
is synthesized, we have a lot of control over this
data and the AI understands what much of this data
means. So with all that extra knowledge, what else
can we do with this footage? For instance, we can
not just reconstruct, but create arbitrary head
movement. We can guess what the real head movement
is because we have a view of the background,
we can simply remove it, or from the movement of
the background, we can infer what kind of head
movement is taking place. And what’s even better,
we can not only get control over the head movement
and change it, but even remove the movement
from the footage altogether. And, we can also
remove the glasses and pretend to have dressed
properly for an occasion. How cool is that?
Now make no mistake, the paper contains a
ton of comparisons against a variety of other
works as well, here are some, but make sure to
check them all out in the video description.
Now, of course, even this new method isn’t
perfect, for instance, it does not work all
that well in low-light situations, but of course,
let’s leave something to improve for the next
paper down the line. And hopefully, in the near
future, we will be able to seamlessly get in
contact with our loved ones through smart glasses
and egocentric cameras. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!